you have told us so many times in the
past how you are looking forward to the
day where Brittany would release new
music that day has finally come what was
your initial reaction uh it was just so
nice to hear her on the radio again
[Music]
I know how much she loves performing and
singing and uh you know I was so glad
that Elton got her back in the studio
and had a fun song so I hope this leads
to many more that's what he said
now they're almost one I know how's
everything going uh it's amazing you
know it's nice to have a little dad
weekend away so I can sleep so thanks to
my mom and dad for keeping them this
weekend uh but it's just been incredible
they're just good kids
like what are the Milestones that
they're hitting right now well I mean
they've been crawling like I mean
they're the fastest crawlers I've ever
seen it's like creepy like it's like a
horror film it's weird give them the
medals already yeah and now you know
they're they're about to take their
first step any second of course it's
going to happen while I'm here nope nope
we're not speaking that into existence I
did that we were in Miami and then I
went out with uh some friends and they
did their first crawl with my my in-laws
I'm like I missed the first crawl now
I'm gonna miss the first step it's okay
you'll be there for the first words
that's right it's all good how will you
guys celebrate the first birthday are
you gonna go all out I mean probably not
crazy look they're not gonna remember it
so I'm not gonna be that person that
just because it's all about the parents
uh but why I ask because some people do
go all out and then others I will when
they remember it they're gonna have a
crazy good party but you know it's it's
always Halloween season they're gonna
like Usher the Halloween in so
especially when their birthday is on the
13th on a Friday the 13th
um so yeah I'm just excited to have
really fun Halloween birthdays every
year well I was gonna say we know you
love Halloween and so that's where
you'll go all out do you have their cost
costumes yet and will they be matching
oh what will they be
we have right now eight costumes
eight
um they're really cute some match some
don't but uh I think on their on
Halloween
they're gonna be dumb and dumber and uh
you know the orange tuxedo
because my son looks just like Jim
Carrey in that movie because he has like
a little chipped tooth and his little
hair
um something like we are going to be
dumb and dumber what will you be I don't
know because nothing really goes with
Dumb and Dumber so family costumes out I
don't know the Shag van like just wear a
button and just be singing Mockingbird
ma yeah yeah
I don't know but uh we're gonna have so
much fun we have lots of pumpkin patches
to go to apple picking like I've I've
been waiting to have kids just so that I
can enjoy the holidays so much more
that's literally when I asked you what
are you most looking forward to about
father out there so I used
to I use love seeing how happy
fatherhood has made you the smile on
your face warms my heart now I want to
talk a little bit business now you and
Danielle official teaming up for a
project this is really awesome who had
the idea uh it was Danielle she she
called me I was in Chicago and she's
like
had this idea she's I do think it'd be
fun to produce our prom night story I
like
yeah because you know 90s are the thing
right now and it's the most 90s story in
the world 1999
Topanga and Lance Bass going to prom
together uh it was just a fun moment in
time and you know it's a very relatable
story especially for people in the
closet because a lot of a lot of you
ladies went to prom with a gay guy so my
my anticipation of the night was
completely different from what her
anticipation of the night was my anxiety
was at a level 10 and she thought she
was gonna be losing her virginity and uh
you'll see how it yeah it pans out have
you found your Lance in Dan yeah no no
we're uh we're just signing our studio
now so it's got a lot of development uh
we do have the writers you know Mary
Holland and uh Lauren Lapkus who are
great comedic actresses on their own but
they're going to be writing it uh and
then yeah the casting process will be
fun because you know it's a teen movie
so we get to like
create some fresh faces and create some
Stars okay so when you have an update ET
will be your first call you better
believe it
thank you